alors noah manoir est avec nous policier
syndicaliste hauteur de la france doit
savoir nos axes
vous êtes policier ancien des
renseignements généraux vous êtes aussi
syndicaliste vous êtes renseigné sur le
dossier de villeneuve la garenne
est-ce que vous pouvez nous donner les
détails de ce qui s'est passé à votre
avis c'est votre c'est votre avis
ou bien soir bonsoir effectivement alors
il ya une enquête qui est en cours donc
bien là même plusieurs qui sont censées
mettre en lumière différents aspects de
ces mêmes événements
donc moi je voudrais rectifier la
présentation qui a été faite pas votre
journaliste
en tout cas la compléter par ce qu'il
est effectivement dit dans les divers
témoignages que le policier sentait
fortement l'alcool mais dès le soir même
quand tout comme dans le cadre de tous
les accidents de voie publique les
accidents corporels et des dépistages
ont été effectués vos confrères du point
rapporte que les dépistages alcoolémie
et stupéfiants des fonctionnaires de
police sont strictement négatif
donc il faut d'action de fermer cette
porte c'est une rumeur totalement
infondée qui visait à salir la
réputation de nos collègues
la deuxième chose c'est que un certain
nombre d'internautes source twitter ont
diffusé le portrait robot en fait la
photo de notre collègue en épinglant en
quelque sorte en appelant au meurtre en
fait très clairement j'ai elle affiche
près de moi si je pense que vous pouvez
me croire sur parole donc on l'a appelé
au meurtre de ce policier donc je
voudrais aussi tout de suite fermé cette
porte en appelant justement la justice à
enquêter
ce que cet aspect des choses qu'on
appelle au calme naturellement alors ça
c'est effectivement un troisième point
si vous voulez la jeunesse nous écoute à
ces plantes haine parce qu'il est prévu
sur villeneuve la garenne et villepinte
chalonnais soyons concernés par les
violences urbaines
et si vous voulez on est en période de
confinement du monde excédé dans les
quartiers bien sûr plus qu'ailleurs
parce que les gens vivent les uns sur
les autres
il ya quand même un climat de tension
apparent et brûlé la voiture de vos
voisins à brûler les commerces de
proximité ça ne résoudra absolument
aucun problème
donc il faut arrêter avec tout ça voilà
vous voyez là ce qui est bien sûr vous
sur votre plateau d'invités c'est qu'on
est tous des enfants de la banlieue y
compris moi même j'ai grandi en banlieue
donc il y a personne pour à me chanter
le racisme ce soir pas de soi tiens ça
de l'intérieur on n'est pas une île ce
soir ce soir c'est important de remettre
les choses au clair et surtout
d'appeler au calme je pense qu'on va
avoir les témoignages des deux de chacun
d'entre vous parce que c'est vrai qu'on
est en période de confinement et
aujourd'hui voilà on aimerait que tout
rentre dans l'ordre que ce soit
villeneuve la garenne ou ailleurs parce
que déjà le moment est très très
difficile et je pense qu'on a besoin
d'une solidarité de tous les instants
alors que noah manoir juste pour savoir
comment ce sont vous vous avez enquêter
là dessus le jeune homme est ce qu il
était connu des services de police ou
pas absolument alors le procureur a
diffusé le procureur de la république a
diffusé un communiqué ce soir il a été
condamné parce je parle pas des mises en
cause il a été condamné 14 fois par la
justice il a il faisait l'objet
au moment des faits d'un contrôle
judiciaire il était placé sous contrôle
judiciaire pour une menace de mort avec
arme c'est elle qui l'avait menacé une
personne avec un hachoir
donc au moment des faits qu'il avait
déjà été verbalisé trois fois pour avoir
violé le confinement et ils se
déplaçaient à bord d'un véhicule non
homologué donc à deux roues pour lequel
il n'était pas détenteur d'un permis de
conduire
lebel donc sans éclairage d'accord donc
sans casque comment dire donc qu'il
avait la police était intervenue dans le
quartier parce que les riverains étaient
complètement excédé par le bruit de
cyclomoteurs c'était une moto cross qui
faisait énormément de bruit donc il
était presque 22 heures les gens des
quartiers vivaient confiné un ibis
toujours confiné et il était totalement
excédée parce qu'ils avaient des enfants
qui cherchent à dormir etc et donc on a
voulu à un moment effectivement présenté
ce monsieur comme un bon père de famille
à mon sens il était peut-être un il a
peut-être des enfants pour qui
effectivement il a une affection
particulière mais c'est pas le profil de
la victime idéale en tout cas moi je me
suis beaucoup dresser contre les
violences policières et moment où je
suis aujourd'hui tout ça la vérité avec
ce monsieur
noam noam juste est-ce que le policier
est ce qu'il a ouverts volontairement la
porte pour stopper le motard ou pas je
ne pense pas celle enquête qu'il
déterminera ce que c'est ça le plus
important marie curie qui n'aurait
aucune raison de ne pas le croire parce
que si on va arrêter une motocyclette à
pleine vitesse je pense pas qu'on puisse
le faire quand on a la possibilité de
faire barrage avec le véhicule de le
faire avec la portière mais de toute
façon l'enquêté tant pour le policier
lui le déterminera et l'igpn donnera ses
conclusions
la suite on en pensera ce qu'on voudra
mais en tout cas moi j'ai aucune raison
aujourd'hui de penser qu'il s'agit d'un
acte volontaire
et de toute façon la personne
aujourd'hui qui bénéficie de la
présomption d'innocence et palm os tard
c'est le policier parce qu'aujourd'hui
la personne contre qui les riverains se
sont offusqués ils ont fait appel à la
police
la personne qui roulait sans plaque
d'immatriculation sans casque sans
permis à bord d'un véhicule interdit en
l'agglomération c'est le motard
aujourd'hui voilà donc aujourd'hui si
vous voulez le bénéfice du doute ne lui
ne lui qu'elle ne vient pas retient pas